ship called the mayflower left plymouth
england carrying 102 passengers
at an assortment of religious
separatists seeking a new home
from where they could freely practice
their faith in other individuals lord by
promise of prosperity
and land ownership in the new world can
i say
let me just add that and it was a bad
thing
um we wish it didn't happen it led to
bad things
it was an infringement encroachment on
cultures and we're putting we're
retroactively putting
those ships yeah on notice yeah
unnoticed the whole that whole i know
that remove that section from your
history book remove it
i love this unknown this is the greatest
thing let me just say
when people talk about thanksgiving and
everyone's like the way americans have
been taught
that thanksgiving that this is like
these manifested it's like
my in my day they would teach us no
it was evil the puritans people acting
like they teach you in school anything
but negative
stuff since 1965. they don't right right
you know people act like this imaginary
world of the 50s has existed this whole
time
it has not in a few select school
districts so what you're basically
saying
is the the russians infiltrated our
school system even earlier than we
thought
da exactly yes they were teaching the
anti-american propaganda
way back yeah it's like i love how
people are doing
thanksgiving all right white people and
columbus all that it's like
the disease smallpox killed more [ __ ]
people than anybody
smallpox it wasn't white people it was
smallpox it was another thing the
chinese created in their lab
1789 george washington in the
continental congress
issued the first thanksgiving
proclamation no the first one was
abraham lincoln
according to binky stats uh during the
american revolution continental congress
designated one or more days of
thanksgiving a year and in 1789 george
washington issued the first thanksgiving
proclamation let me tell you something
by the national government
that's lavin read that off he read that
off like a placemat at the white stone
diner
being an irish being an irish german
italian who knows whatever you want to
be yeah from the brook
whatever you're live telling people i
know i know colin feels the same way
i don't even know if i can celebrate
christmas because they have cancer the
thanksgiving day parade so if i don't
see santa tailing at the end of that
macy's thanksgiving day parade i don't
know if we can even do christmas that's
a good point how do you feel about that
yeah this is this is crazy i can't
believe nuts they could have the parade
those what are you afraid of getting
covered from those [ __ ] uh the floats
yeah i mean uh giannis says the only
reason cuomo's even sticking around
right now
is because he can make a [ __ ] good
sauce yeah he couldn't make a sauce he'd
be done that's the thing
me and chris talked about that like if
you have like a fight with an italian
friend like if you fight with like an
irish or german friend
there's no way for them to ever really
win you back really but if you have a
fight with an italian friend then he
invites you over sunday
and and and the sauce is just right yeah
you have a change of heart
you know it is true they really forgive
yeah people think it's like a cliche but
they really when the sauce is right
and the other thing is that christmas
eve sauce they used to have with the
fried seven fishes
that [ __ ] was unbelievable their mothers
would make it not them but
i remember my friends and just going how
the hell is this this is unbelievable
let me ask you this all the best
memories well here's some questions
that's gonna go to the bay bridge story
yeah or should i told you yes i should
ask
yesterday yeah yeah [ __ ] prepare them
a little bit well well one thanks
i'll give you a thanksgiving one then
we'll go eat pizza um
that's the problem with pizza if it's
cold it's dead we could just we could
tell the story will pause the podcast
and come right back up oh i love it
what's high tech um well one beyblade
story
which was um that one one thanksgiving
go to my grandmother's house on 72nd 5th
and 6th
and uh i i absconded some pals like 16.
so i absconded some pills from somewhere
i took them from somebody's medicine
cabinet
that was a big 70s move and i took them
and i went into convulsions in the
middle of thanksgiving
and then they rushed me to the hospital
[ __ ] my mommy's which
you better it's like you're safer just
going right to a funeral yeah
yeah and that's right i know mamadise my
mommy's where my daughter was born they
had me cut the umbilical cord
[Music]
and and they had to pump my stomach on
this
i didn't even eat the ultimate thing
yeah yeah well it's [ __ ] dude
by the way thanksgiving is one of those
day one of the most
biggest car accidents domestic abuse
um heart attacks because the food it's
the most
i think it's probably the i bet if we
looked it up it's the most
uh dangerous i don't like it's gonna
look it up turkey's dry
i don't like it cranberry sauce is gross
you know it's not a
great food if you have it just on
thanksgiving and it's it's the
name of your mortal kombat stuffing's
okay yeah
turkey without the gravy's too dry yeah
and [ __ ] my house right
yeah my [ __ ] uh girl's a vegan so
also what we did to the indians
i don't want to celebrate that several
reasons why thanksgiving is the most
dangerous holiday let's see if any of
secretaries
are accidents one heart attacks too oh
look at number three uh odin
on pills that you stole from your
friends fires
food poisoning poisoning dog bites what
trips and falls and food allergies yeah
wow yep that's also dangerous but is it
the most dangerous holiday
i would say that maybe new year's eve
might be the only other one
yeah fourth of july is the most
dangerous fourth of july's gonna be the
worst yeah i think it depends
right i mean i think it depends i mean
it depends on where you are and what you
celebrate like right well
if you ask palestinians maybe ramadan if
you live in certain areas i mean
they're not eating they're fasting and
getting behind the wheel low blood sugar
yeah
it's tough easter was another one since
we back when i was a kid and my mother
just still used to love to tell the
story she's alive i made it by me when i
was like seven because there's so many
black kids as their neighbors were so
mixed and i
i made a buy me a purple suit for
thanksgiving
because all the black kids were like
purple clothes and great yeah so i'll be
walking around the purple suit on
thanksgiving i mean on easter
yeah easter outfit was that there was a
kid on your block who had
had a mud floor oh yes which i can't
believe
yes no the whole family yeah they didn't
have a floor what there were 12 of them
yeah 12 to 14 kids on our corner irish
no black and they had a they had dirt
floors
and we would just we would say hey go
home and water your floor that would
lead to fights